all the different things that we do here
are relatively simple they just look
complex that's just a testament to how
clever how good of a job the team did
and make it work in a beautiful fashion
my name is Michael Caron and I'm the
director of control and today we'll go
through the Astraeus first instance when
we talked about - tremors was actually
in the synopsis of the game it was a
really simple idea at the time the idea
of this kind of a lock almost a kind of
location in the world that stops your
progression here we see a concept or
drawing and this actually illustrates
many different elements that we were
thinking about and you can actually see
a smaller entry over here about the maze
and as you can see from the image yeah
it's an early early kind of a
visualization of what the mesh would be
I personally wanted it to be this kind
of labyrinth and then there's this thing
in the middle and you need to kind of
find your way through it
plus we went through it looked at the
story I look at the kind of big parts
and so on it was clear that we need to
shift our thinking towards it being more
like an area that they have to get true
but you can see how we we think about
the context of things compared to other
elements so the maze was there to stop
you from getting to the dimensional
research sector you can come to this
place but early on you don't really
understand what it is or what it does
there are a few hints of elements nearby
you can see over here like artists
equipment a bit of trash and so on it's
a sign of things to come that you might
not realize yet so here we are first
time entering the maze wondering what's
going on and what's happening and and
the maze does this thing where it's just
redirect you back to where you started
off from at this point of the game of
course you're wondering what this is and
I think it's great to do things like
that it's not something that they have
really done you know games before but
there's this way to access and see
things there are big mystery still
and I leave it haunting the player a bit
and so on and then you'll know when the
moment happens when you come back to it
but once you know that you need to go
through it do you find a note from Artie
saying that you know it's under
maintenance really enough we come to
Artie basically he gives us this tape
recorder allows us to listen to music so
turns out music is the key to get
through the maze here we are back at the
maze
ready to rock but this time Jessie have
tape recorders she can start listening
to the song it makes sense that we would
use the old gods of Osgood as the band
and that kind of started off the
collaboration with pause at the fall who
who are actually the band behind old
gods of Oscars we kind of worked with
them before so it was a natural thing
for us to do and they are really good at
what they do
also in the technical sense they can
work directly with our audio team and
technical team to make sure that they
establish the song in a way that allows
our team to actually break it down in
such a way that we can make this song
adapt to the situation and it's more
complicated than what it sounds
basically we had to make sure that the
song for loss is in a kind of our goes
through certain kind of motions but at
the same time we need to be able to
react to whatever the play is doing he
or she might stop at any given time and
the song has to kind of just work with
that whatever happens yet at the same
time it needs to sound natural like a
normal song that we expect to hear in a
club or somewhere so it couldn't break
that immersion couldn't break that sense
of illusion of what we are creating and
of course part of this is a big reveal
in a way that hey this is a connected
universe I mean this is connecting
directly to a long way
[Music]
it's off the same band but it sounds a
bit different it's a bit rougher and so
on a bit more energetic and brutal so it
feels right in the world that we're
creating here today and here you can see
the the structure of the maze and the
kind of flow through it what's
interesting is that when people play
through it it comes across as a complex
flow there's a lot of things happens
it's love shifting but the actual
structure of the environment is fairly
straightforward and we had a very
modular approach here which helped us a
lot because we are not at the end of the
day one of the big teams I mean to be
clever with how we work so here you can
actually see that it's early on it was
called smoke-and-mirrors maze we changed
the name because there was this object
that it was related to and so on so we
wanted it to be a separate lure for that
we often come up with names for things
because it makes it easier to talk about
them and then as we move forward and we
kind of figure out that final names when
you look at it like this looks simple
it's really all about the execution of
the animation of the environment the
shifting kind of different things we do
with the enemies when they're spawn how
they're spawn and so on and that creates
that illusion of complexity to the
environment so here's some concept image
from Leonardo we have this sense of
repetition and symmetry and using this
kind of mundane looking Motel as a
background here's another one I
especially like this because it looks
not creepy but there's this sense of an
ominous tone to it there was this idea
early on that it would have this visual
theme of a hotel then it was connected
to the movie button think which has this
kind of a eerie strange hotel that is
kind of like falling apart a bit like
literally so we took that as a kind of a
stunning point for the whole thing but
here's the kind of visual aesthetic for
the environment
using symmetry through the entire game
felt just right from the get-go and and
me and Sam will be concept this game
right after quantum break we talked
about Kubrick and kind of a careful
approach to the camera everything has
meaning that you see in the image and
there's a sense of balance between
things symmetry plays a big part of that
is something that I also personally feel
like is at the essence of their static
of control overall as a game when you
see a shot of control with symmetry you
kind of recognize that it is control
without even realizing it and that's
what I think is important there's this
sense of visual identity you don't see
symmetry in life that often and when is
artificially built like this it creates
a sense of unease that's also a huge
part of what we wanted to do in the game
that symmetry plays that kind of
emotional role as well right so what
we're looking at now is early footage of
a prototype that we did everything is
white box so we have this kind of a
simple environment and some kind of a
basic lighting so that we can actually
tell the shapes from each other can
understand the structure of the
environment and so on I think we're
using Chuck choices animation actually
from from quantum early place all this
stuff so yeah he he looks a bit weird
but here you can see the early visuals
and how we started to put it together
again it's the the maze was about
opening up opportunities and closing
them off subverting expectations type of
thing happening keeping you on your toes
a bit trying to kind of see what is
happening in the environment and what to
react to and what not to react to it is
extremely strange to watch this footage
to be honest I'm a very visual person I
think in a visual way I use references a
lot of these concepts a lot I look a lot
about images that convey the end result
that we want to achieve it's always
weird to work in a white boxing face
because you kind of firm you see a lot
of that thinking you have to you need to
look at the structure and and kind of
focus on what are the important base
right now too
and then at the back of your head you
think a bit about okay what is the
overall experience from an aesthetic
perspective we want to achieve later on
and make sure that it doesn't become
impossible with the decisions that you
do today it's a complex thing that you
need to be aware of at all times and
also just for the sake of sanity of the
team you need to keep them focused as
well like let's just worry about this
thing today tomorrow we'll worry about
other things and as you go forward you
build this understanding of what you're
creating as I said before a creativity
is a process like you don't you have
some ideas you have a direction
initially this is what I want to do but
as you start working on it you kind of
course correct you realize that actually
this thing that I was thinking about
before doesn't make sense or it doesn't
work it's not good but it's better like
this instead so you keep shifting things
and you build this understanding you
build this big mountain this big
building for yourself like this is the
experience that we had as you work on it
and you go through that for three years
and you look at the game it gets better
and better and better and and towards
the end you kind of change this little
little details and so it's a bit of a
shock it has to go back this kind of two
years and see oh damn this is what we
started with Wow and it makes you pause
always because you kind of built that
understanding for yourself and the kind
of cathartic moment almost and and fun
as well because it makes you feel proud
like what you can do here's an awesome
moment where you could already see early
on that this is going to be cool this
kind of a sense of transforming the
environment in an unexpected way there
is this kind of a feeling of not knowing
how to react to what's going on and
there's like this few seconds of panic
that you might have like what do I do
now so and that felt great and that's
exactly what we wanted to get out from
the shifting maze and here you can see
like again the sense of not moving
through the flow in a way that you
expect that the opening is actually at
the ceiling and not you know
at your level and then finding your way
through there I think if she's part of
the magic for the masses that there is
certain kind of simplicity to the
structure of it you never see that
complicated setup then and that was huge
part of like the overall direction of it
if we started to make it too complicated
and that's too started to kind of take
away the narrative of what it was
obviously it's not the real motel it's
just a strange dimensional expression of
something that is constructed out of
nothing the point was that it's kind of
using this visuals of a motel in in a
wrong way and like stretch way and so on
I'm sure many people remember the moment
where you come into a room and then
there were like a number of enemies that
appear roughly over here and then we
actually closed that those kind of a
walls in front of them so you're like
should I go I shouldn't and then you
just kind of move on again subverting
expectations and this I'm sure people
recognize towards the end a big vertical
space again it's all about creating this
story that you go through and the
important bit about stories is there's a
sense of evolution progression you move
on to the next place and it needs to be
something new something that surprises
you so here we have a version of the
maze a bit later not much compared to
the piece for this year you can see a
bit more elaborate effects being used
for the shifting it feels a bit more
3-dimensional you can see the different
kind of at the symmetry like of
different elements moving at the same
pace and so on again creating that sense
of unnatural motion start to see hints
of what it will become later the the
basic principle is that there's this
feeling of an unfolding it's not quite
like the shifting you see elsewhere in
the building because this is a bit
different thing it creates this strange
reaction to you like that there's kind
of layers of elements kind of a moving
and together it works beautifully
but again symmetry is important to us
there's this kind of a layering that is
happening here as well to create that
three-dimensional feel what's clever
about this is that with this number of
different smaller VFX elements we can
create epic feeling moments regarding
the shifting so I was a bit worried
about natural elements that will it look
weird like like a doors and like a
detail like will it fold in a way that
looks broken but no it doesn't looks
fantastic I did internally think about
the shifting that much early on to me it
was this strange maze they have to get
true but once I saw the VFX test for
answer from blood it kind of transformed
a bit as an experience and it kind of
bumped up a bit amongst all the
different measures that we were doing so
here we have the final kind of version
of the maze and you can see how many of
the things have come together and you
can see a lot of familiar moments there
was this kind of part of creating
expectation setting up a situation
actually have like five doors next to
each other and so on and each one keeps
opening up and there's this little kind
of moment of like I wonder what's going
to be revealed behind it I mean this is
a fairly straightforward action mission
at the end of the day and yes early on
we think about puzzles or you know maybe
have multiple different routes and maybe
take that route or do another one as we
worked on it and it kind of taking the
music into account and trying to get a
feel of what are we doing overall
there's this simple kind of phrase of
use like less is more like let's just
focus on the essential thing let's leave
out elements that makes you pause and
think about things that are necessarily
not the focus right now the focus is to
have this energetic battle this fight
through this complex shifting place and
and just leave everything else out and
ultimately all the different things that
we do here are relatively simple they
just look complex that's just a
testament to how clever how good of a
job the team did with not a lot of time
and make it work in a beautiful fashion
we didn't have to follow any normal
world rules we can have boxes like this
they
that don't make any sense we can bring
them in we can make them go away
allowing us to create a very dynamic
unexpected yet at the same time expected
environment so the team could have a lot
of fun with that and create moments that
maybe weren't that common in in the
normal flow of the game here again we
can see us kind of using some kind of a
basic motives of with the lies you can
see it connecting to the bottom thing
thing we have the shoes here sense of
symmetry you're getting to this kind of
a default visual of where you are what
is this place when I started to see like
the first versions where all of the
different assets that we had been
creating for months finally being there
in the environment with the right
lighting yeah I almost cried it was it's
just like it looks so great it looked
perfect with that strong visual tone
that we wanted to have with this game
something that stood out compared to
everybody else we're doing your own
thing our own unique IP so it was super
exciting very nerve-wracking as well but
a huge part of why I think we all do
this job and again what I love about
this environment is it's so simple it's
just rows of doors going into darkness
it kind of feels different and it feels
strong in its simplicity and now we're
out from the maze we did it we got
through it
then I just want to talk how important
is for remedy that it's a team effort so
it's a lot of people coming together
working together figuring things out
overcoming problems and each one is
needed to really create something
exceptional so here we have vladislav
from the left who was the VFX artist
that we have miko working on music and
he and Martin who is next to me on the
right they were basically the magicians
who kind of figured out how to handle
that song in a way that adapts to what
the players doing at the player stop the
music and just works with that most
people program they even realize it how
complex that is to make it sound natural
but it kind of just
works and these two guys were behind
that then this anna-marie she is the
level designer basically responsible or
figuring the flow out and and kind of
taking all the different bits and pieces
making them come together and a lot of
the orchestration of the different
events that's by her as well she also
did many of the simple floor animations
and so on so she was essential to put
all of these different things together
then we have Marcel who's the
environment artist and then Leonardo his
concept artist so Leonardo early on
basically put those images together to
kind of illustrate the overall aesthetic
the sense of the you know the vertical
elements the symmetry tone that the
motel brings to the environment and all
of that stuff and then Marcel is the
environmentalist and Leonardo and Mossad
together worked a lot to figure all this
different bits together and must have
basically responsible of actually
implementing it I think the maze overall
is it's a successful exercise from
aesthetic perspective as well because I
do think that if you would show even a
small bed of this environment to anybody
who's played they immediately know like
yes that's the maze and can be a tiny
detail or a bigger thing the art
director Jana Paul keener together with
the VFX team then Marmont others did a
fantastic job it's Ted McDonald as well
who was the world design director the
person who kind of came up with all
these little details have different
things work the doors that shoes all of
the stuff again a lot of people come
together creating something unique the
the popularity of the Masons reception
to me surprised us a bit and to be
honest I'm not sure why because we
should have known already but still
we've kind of caught off guard a bit but
it kind of verified to us that what
we're doing as an independent small
studio it's important that we stick the
things that belongs to us and kind of
all things that only we are doing out
there and believe in that and not kind
of make the mistake of shying away from
something that might be a bit strange or
a bit
you whimsical and so on and instead be
ready to embrace that and trust that and
players will always get it they will
always have fun they will always
appreciate when we're doing something
different that is refreshing and fun and
unpure in in many ways and it kind of
got reaffirmed I think in a way that yes
that's the case and I think it will act
as guidance for us in the future as well
stick to our guns and and be who we are
and not shy away from that